well look the government have been in
government now for 12 years
boris johnson and priti patel have been
in charge
of this issue now for nearly three years
and even in that three years that
they've been in charge the number of
small boat crossings coming from uh
across the channel
has gone up tenfold it's doubled in the
last year and it's doubling uh
every few months now so this is
happening under their watch
they haven't taken the steps to deal
with this this issue and we all want it
dealt with it needs dealing with
criminal gangs exploiting people to make
these dangerous crossings uh putting
pressure on our
on our immigration system and on our
border forces and so on it needs dealing
with but the steps that the government
could have made
over over recent months and years
they haven't done so and i'm afraid you
know this announcement this morning has
to be taken with a great deal of a big
dollop really of cynicism and skepticism
about the timing of it and whether this
is actually all about distracting from
the prime minister's own law breaking
and uh the the kind of terrible state
that his government's in rather than
than dealing with this issue at all
well i suppose it's going to play well
in the shires especially among
conservative voters and we do have
elections coming up local elections in
just a couple of weeks time it's exactly
the sort of thing that labour would do
if they were in power
well no it isn't actually yeah and
you're right it
almost certainly does play well in the
focus groups and it is headline grabbing
and it seems sort of controversial and
contestable in in that sense but all the
evidence tells us that it's unworkable
it's incredibly expensive
and it's unethical um a similar scheme
that australia and it's designed on this
scheme that happens in in australia
where they offshore people in papua new
guinea
the evidence from that scheme says that
that scheme is costing 1.7 million
pounds per person
to process people uh offshore so we're
talking about billions of pounds here
that the government is committing when
actually what they could be doing
is first of all processing uh asylum
applications far more quickly than they
are doing which is why we're seeing
people having you know months and years
um in an expensive hostel and hotel
accommodation because they're not
getting quick decisions they need to
come to these return agreements with
with other countries which since we left
the eu they've not been able to do so
even when an asylum application is is
not granted the government is unable to
return people um
to countries that either they came from
or they passed through because they
haven't got
return of great agreements there's more
that can be done to stop these criminal
gangs advertising and making money out
of these schemes amendments we've put
down in the house of commons which the
government hasn't supported so you know
with real determination and leadership
from the home office frankly
leadership and determination we just
don't see
um you know this this issue could be
tackled and under their watch under
pretty patel and boris johnson's watch
this issue has got absolutely totally
out of control
and
and that's why we're seeing this this
policy being brought forward but don't
you have to accept um shadow secretary
today that um it will allow us whether
you agree with the process or not it
will allow us to better protect our
borders
well i don't think there's any evidence
to suggest that it's not going to put
people you know people are being
exploited by criminal gangs they're
being promised the earth they're being
promised uh a lie they're being promised
a route into this country that doesn't
exist people aren't knowingly paying
lots of money to put their own lives at
risk on a small boat to just then be um
kind of locked up in in a hostel
for many many months uh while uh while
our application is in limbo that's not
what people are being promised i don't
think this is actually gonna put put
that many people off in that sense it's
incredibly expensive
um and there's lots of question marks
over whether it's it's workable so as i
say i think this is this is not about
tackling uh the small boats issue this
is about tackling the government's own
sinking boat issue because we've got a
prime minister now who's been um found
to have broken the law in his own
premises a law that he made only a few
months earlier that we were all um you
know totally complying with and he
doesn't want us to have that
conversation anymore he wants us to have
this conversation well not on this show
we'll certainly still be having that
conversation but uh nevertheless your
leader uh initially said that he wanted
the prime minister to resign and then he
said actually what's going on in ukraine
means that there are other things that
are more important at the moment and now
he's saying that again that he wants the
prime minister and the chancellor to
resign can he not make his mind up
well i think to be fair he's been very
consistent about this issue you know the
the prime the prime minister
has at best uh misled parliament
um he has now been fined
and therefore found guilty of a criminal
offense by the metropolitan police
whilst in office
uh not just any law or you know an
insignificant law but laws that we were
all uh
dutifully following um to keep others
safe and to stop ourselves also being
found uh you know
breaking the law
we're now told that there were going to
be more fines to follow so this is not
just a one-off so we know all of that
shadow minister forgive me we know all
of that but my point is that your leader
has changed his mind twice now on what
should happen why can't he just be
consistent
well i don't think he has changed his
mind look i think you know in in that in
that very
you know moment of of the of the war
breaking out in ukraine when asked about
whether this was something he was still
calling for he was saying well look i
still believe he should resign but there
are other issues at this moment in time
obviously that's now um you know become
clearer again that that you know this is
now a huge distraction for the
government not only is is the law
breaking in of itself a real problem and
that i think the public are pretty clear
about their opinion about what the prime
minister should do but it's also
stopping this government from
functioning you know they're not able to
deal with the issues facing us like like
the energy crisis not the time for the
prime minister to quit so he's called
for his resignation then he changed his
mind and said now is not the time for
the pm to quit and now he's saying it is
the time for the pm to quit even though
the situation in ukraine remains the
same so i don't get it
well it was just that moment in in time
at that point in time as you know the
war in ukraine was uh unfolding that was
before we knew that the fines were going
to be issued you know i think you know
we all would have said a few weeks ago
we would have said in the middle of
lockdown of course if we if the prime
minister was being fined for breaking
lockdown rules there would have been no
question that the prime minister should
have resigned of course he should have
done and he still should
and and we're going to see more fines uh
coming and i think it makes his position
completely untenable and we are facing
we are facing a big crisis in ukraine
and we are facing a big crisis at home
with people not able to put food on the
table or to heat their homes and what
they need is a government proactively
supporting them providing um you know
relief in meeting those those bills and
we're not able to see that because we've
got a government that's completely
dysfunctional
a government and a prime minister trying
to save their own skin the whole time
and and that's why we do urgently need a
change of leadership i'm afraid
okay thanks for joining us as always
much appreciated hopefully you'll come
in and see us in the studios sometime
thank you